remember we used to just put our cards
in the thing then take them out you used
to just give the credit card to the guy
before that you just use cash right you
just give cash and then the guy would
take the cash and then give you more
cash I gave you one and now I gotta have
all this [__] that sucks more stuff
that's actually less
I'm not a part of it you'll give them
like one dollar if something is 45 cents
and then you get back like two quarters
in a nickel or even worse three dimes
two nickels and
two more nickels and then another nickel
but then they invented the credit cards
money's [__] credit card's cool you
give the guy the credit card the guy
takes a credit card does the thing and
then gives it back and you gotta sign it
too much then they came up with the
[__] you slide the credit card thing
in great take it out great I do the
credit card [__] now but now it's like
either slide it or put it in for a
little bit
or just put it around the area
pick one this is your [__]
establishment I have the card what the
[__] is there to do
everybody's got the [__] tap [__]
so if you just want to make it to tap
[__]
tell me to just wave it around the area
now that doesn't this is one of those
things the technology is not caught up
to the thing because a lot of times
they're like yeah the top function
actually it doesn't really work
so slide it in and you're like ah all
right I'm just getting used to the tap
[__] now but fine it's completely
[__] annoying
I want to go back to the days where you
just take my credit card do what it is
you need to do now all people are like
oh yeah but it's safety in Australia
they've been doing it forever and so is
Britain and it's like okay yeah I guess
it's safer if some not everybody's
holding my credit card but whatever dude
here's the [__] annoying part there's
too many screens now
you tap it they go okay is this amount
okay yes
okay you want
tip
uh all right and then give you like
three or four options for a tip it'll be
like 10 20 30 like first of all the
balls right
like 20 okay and I do 30 a lot of the
time but most people ain't [__] we
fly high No Lie we roll in but since I'm
the kind of guy who we fly high No Lie
we rolling
[Music]
right so I'm like well I can't not tip
30 and then somebody tweets out any
doesn't tip well
if I don't do it to get in right with
[__] Jesus I do it because you know
what this coffee the tip is two dollars
[__] it who cares right you see the ten
percent and then you see the 20 and then
you see the 30 so everybody knows the
left side is the little tip if that's
what you want to do
sometimes companies are Savvy like
sandwich places like Mom and Pop places
they'll flip it and put the 30 first
then 20 and then 10. so you think
automatically you go Boop and hit the 30
even though you think you're hitting the
10 and then you go ah [__] it and then
sign the thing and hit it right dude
that is some [__] [__] [__] that's
undercover that's like the [__]
GoFundMe how they they add the tip in
already
they say you're going to get 15 right
and you go what what and you got to
unclick it
that's a bit like robbery it's an
unspoken thing so it's not like robbery
but it's an unspoken thing but we all
know that the money's supposed to go
little money to the left and then upper
upper bigger money to the right but
here's the deal thank God you're
listening to this podcast because this
is very important and like And subscribe
honestly when you get to the tip screen
and you walk away sometimes you don't
think you're like I hit the thing I
gotta go away now and then they and then
the tip screen is left open right and
the guy behind the thing is like oh [__]
he didn't do the tip screen
never once have I ever heard the guy say
oh man you didn't do the tip screen not
once in my life have I ever heard that
but I have heard
people say oh it's asking you some
questions
now we know what's going on there
they don't want to sound greedy
[Laughter]
and I get why they do it and they don't
want to put you in that uncomfortable
situation where it's like oh [__] yeah I
wasn't gonna give you a tip I was gonna
put zero but I [__] up now you was
you're looking at me doing because you
know I didn't do it so
dude today the guy goes like this not
even like he didn't even do it any sort
of I understand you don't want to say oh
you didn't do the tip but he goes like
this it was well across the coffee place
because I forgot to click all the
[__] buttons he says oh man it's
still asking you a question
and I go I say huh and he says it's
still asking you a question I'm like oh
I walk over and I say yeah yeah and I
give him a 30 tip because you know what
I mean
those are the things I think about
all day long
[Music]
crazy congratulations